meanwhile we got a big update on the
migrants who have been accused of
attacking New York City police officers
last week over by Times Square remember
this well ey sources tell Fox News that
several of those people in these images
have been apprehended apparently in
Phoenix unbelievable plus another group
of migrants have been arrested for
allegedly dragging a woman down a New
York City street as they stole her purse
B and Riva joins us right now with the
latest developments update us won't you
hey good morning Brian Steve lawren and
Le so I a lot of things going on but I
do want to begin with the suspects who
are arrested in Phoenix there are still
some details we're waiting for like the
identities of the suspects and which
migrants were arrested but Immigration
and Customs Enforcement sources tell Fox
they're suspected of being involved in
this beating of two NYPD officers in
Times Square remember six suspects were
arrested and charged but only one was
held on cash bail police sources had
told us some of the five who were
released left New York to head to to to
the California Mexico border rather now
it appears based on what multiple eye
sources are telling us that at least
some of their Journeys were cut short
with some suspects being arrested at a
Greyhound bus station in Phoenix Monday
here's New York city mayor Eric
Adams while these five individuals were
are migrants I want to reiterate uh the
overwhelming number of 170 plus thousand
migrant and Asylum Seekers are attempted
to continue their next leg of their
journey of pursuing the American
dream then ypd separately also arresting
seven migrants in an early morning raid
in the Bronx Monday whom officers say
were behind a robbery ring in the city
investigators say the suspects would
ride up behind victims on Stolen mopeds
mostly women walking alone and snatch
their phones and purses the nyp
detailing Fox New Yorkers and tourists
must stay
vigilant wave of Migrant crime has
washed over our city they're essentially
ghost criminals no criminal history no
photos no cell phone no social
media sometimes we're even unclear on a
name or a date of birth and on top of
that these operations are extremely
sophisticated they intentionally try to
evade the
police going back to the assault of the
two NYPD officers Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg is expected to
present evidence to a grand jury today
Steve Ryan lawren and Angley see what
happens it's amazing uh thanks amazing
how interested he is right now yeah oh
okay hey let me Place some evidence
there because he got out they got out
with no bail only one guy was detained
and uh no no look into their criminal
background and they're allowed to go so
they said hey wait a second why don't
they hop on a bus but they were spotted
and recognized and it's so easy would
figure to track a Greyhound bus because
Greyhound could track the bus we can
track the bus so they figured out a way
to track them down and then arrest them
but Isis kept from them so uh in New
York but not in Phoenix yeah I I
apparently they used phony names uh but
the the uh Church charity that carded
them to Phoenix uh apparently accepted
and they got phony IDs too yeah as you
look as you look at those guys who are
being held there you know Chicago is
having a big problem as well and you
were just out there taking a look at it
so yesterday the new mayor uh who's been
in in the office since uh May of last
year remember he replaced Lori Lightfoot
as mayor of Chicago uh he was supposed
to go down to the border and see for his
own for himself in October but he
canceled and he sent a deputy mayor well
he was asked yesterday by by another
reporter hey when are you going to go
and listen to what he had to say to that
reporter about why the mayor is not
going he's got a really good reason
listen do you understand that you have
not had a mayor like me I get that I
have a wife I have children they have
schedules
and plus we still have Public Safety
that we have to address we still have
the UN house that we have to address I
still have a budget that I have to
address and I'm doing all of that with a
black wife raising three black children
on the west side of the city of Chicago
I am going to the Border as soon as
possible but I got to coordinate that
with running the government and making
sure that my wife and children are
secure as well thank you Lord so what
about the single black mothers that live
in Chicago that you caus to Crime to go
because you wanted defund the police
that you support the broken education
system because you support the teachers
ions and not the kids he tried to use
his race as a shield in that segment but
the problems still exists and they're
affecting everyone and they don't have
some of those kids don't have dads in
their life um to deal with those issues
mom's holding down two jobs can't afford
dayare we all have kids we all have busy
schedules but if you're going to run for
mayor you got to do the job I mean I'm
sorry he's doing all that we're all
balancing a lot I mean we all get up
at30 in the morning we have kids I'm a
single mom what does race have to do
with it I don't know zero zero it was to
disarm the reporter and as you can see
it worked because they bagged off but
the bottom line is just got back from
Chicago they're in a world of trouble
black residents are outraged with this
mayor and as you heard from the 91y old
um lady that I interview there she
doesn't think he's cut for the job you
know the Jewish Community is mad at him
too I was just reading this article U it
says that Jewish United Fund denounces
mayor Johnson's tiebreaking vote for
Council ceasefire resolution apparently
some of Chicago's Jewish leaders took
out a full page ad in Sunday's newspaper
strongly denouncing how he's handled the
Gaza ceasefire resolution well you know
here's here's the problem for the people
of Chicago he's going to have three kids
four years so it's like every time he
doesn't do something he's got a built an
excuse I got three kids I've heard a lot
of excuses from politicians but that
tops it right there it so would happen
if we we having a picnic I can't go you
have kids you have grandkids you kid
well deasio had easy cuz he knew where
his kids were they were protesting
against him and against the cops so they
would always be at the riot so I know
where the kids are honey just go find
the lce right wife too so she he knew
where she was oh her Thrive it cost $4
billion right and now they're living
apart together I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis